هل عيد الفطر الجمعه ام السبت هذا السؤال
بات هذه الايام الشغل الشاغل لجميع
المسلمين حول العالم
[موسيقى]
التوقعات الفلكيه اوضحت احتماليه ان يصادف
عيد الفطر يوم الجمعه الموافق الحادي
والعشرين من ابريل الجاري الا ان ظاهره
الكسوف الكلي التي ستحدث في الكثير من دول
العالم في تلك الليله قد تؤدي الى حجم
رؤيه الهلال بالعين المجرده او بواسطه
التلسكوب وفي الحالات المماثله يتم اعتبار
نهايه الشهر القمري باليوم التالي اي في
هذه الحاله يكون اول ايام عيد الفطر يوم
السبت الموافق 22 من ابريل الجاريه
مركز الفلك الدولي كان اصدر بيانا يوضح ان
هناك امكانيه الهلال بالتلسكوب في بعض
اجزاء العالم الاسلامي يوم الخميس ونظرا
لحدوث الاقتران قبل غروب الشمس وغروب
القمر بعد غروب الشمس في مناطق العالم
الاسلامي فقد جرت العاده بمثل هذه الظروف
ان تعلن غالبيه الدول العالم الاسلامي بدء
الشهر في اليوم التالي وعليه من المتوقع
اعلان العديد من الدول عيد الفطر يوم
الجمعه المقبل الموافق الحادي والعشرين من
ابريل
[موسيقى]
فيما اعلنا معهد البحوث الفلكيه المصري
اول ايام عيد الفطر المبارك حيث اوضح رئيس
المعهد انه طبقا للحسابات الفلكيه التي
يقوم بها معمل ابحاث الشمس بالمعهد فان
هلال شهر شوال سيولد في تمام الساعه
السادسه واربعه عشر دقيقه صباحا بتوقيت
القاهره المحلي يوم الخميس التاسع
والعشرين من رمضان
وبالنسبه للدول التي تشترط الرؤيه الصحيحه
بالعين المجرده فقط او تشترط الرؤيه
المحليه الصحيحه ولو بالتلسكوب فيتوقع ان
تكون عده رمضان فيها ثلاثين يوما وان يكون
فيها عيد الفطر يوم السبت المقبل الموافق
22 من ابريل وكانت المحكمه العليا في
السعوديه قد دعت الى تحرير رؤيته لشوال
مساء يوم الخميس المقبل
[موسيقى]
الوصول الى نهايه الجدل الدائري لتحديد
نهايه شهر رمضان المبارك وبدايه شهر شوال
سيستمر الى ليله الرؤيه اي ليله الخميس
حيث نتيجه الرؤيه الميدانيه ستحدد اول
ايام عيد الفطر السعيد وكل عام وانتم بخير
[موسيقى]